where'd you grow up mostly in Washington
DC area
I've got Alexandria Virginia I was born
in Eritrea osmoter same place you've
heard about the rapper Nipsey Hussle
yeah yeah we're from the same country
part of Ethiopia when I was about five
years old my mom brought us over there
having the civil war so we had to sneak
out and she walked in she was like maybe
21 and she had three kids and she went
from Eritrea to Sudan in the desert and
we my first like two years I mean the
next two years we lived in a refugee
camp in Sudan
when the game like to start for you
it started in in DC in high school we
had little cliques
you know things that you know we would
click up meaning we got a group of guys
together and we'd watch each other's
back we didn't take it too seriously but
you know if somebody mess with somebody
it was automatic we would back each
other up I didn't know anything about
gangs except for what I've seen in the
movies and TV shows no no they do but
not like they do here in America well
organized
and then we moved to LA when I was 14
and yeah we moved to Venice shoreline
area and I was I was kind of excited
about these guys they call themselves
the shoreline Crips yeah yeah it's crazy
because for me it was such a nice area
and there's a beach yeah yeah and how
did they what's going on because it on
the East Coast
it's the batter is really tight and you
can tell out here that you know the
areas that are gang-related
you would never know they got nice homes
and everyone got home yeah okay we had
an apartment most of my life but yeah I
just I got hooked to that quick I got
hooked to the in the but tension I got
in school which is weird is it in high
school back in Virginia if you played
sports you got attention out here like
gang members were like low-key you know
popular like everyone respected I wanted
to be like them and I just wanted to do
the same
I was I had two sisters growing up I had
really feminine characteristics I didn't
like about myself I was really small
undersized and I learned how to first
talk and you know like you know how to
communicate violently aggressively make
fun of people because I couldn't fight
and then I started getting bigger
stronger and I still I still wanted to
join other people because I did anything
I could do [ __ ] by myself I mean not to
say that you know gang all gang members
are like that but for me honestly when I
was at that age that's what I was I was
just trying to survive
yeah so I dropped I don't know if you
call it dropped outlet almost made it to
my senior year failed my senior year but
I moved to summer for night school it's
like an alternative school whatever all
the girls are pregnant all the other
kids on parole probation something like
that I still had never touched the
police I see one time I did I mean these
two kids we were walking back to the
football game I grew up with these two
kids and they jumped on these two older
girls and we supported humping where
they just would just grab him and pulled
him in to him and we were in we were in
sixth grade and the girls were like 10th
11th graders coming to find out those
girls with my sister's best friend we
had to go to a hearing where I asked the
girls is like you know I wasn't part of
it you know you know those two and
they're like no you did it too and that
does it for created the first shift in
my family with me my sisters stop
talking to me really my mom was sick had
and looked at me differently and I
thought I'd the kid I thought I had
raped somebody even though I had done
nothing I really felt like I was a rape
you know like a rapist and I just kind
of lived that shame and guilt and then
by joining the gang you know when I
joined the Crips out you know Venice
that kind of stuff was talked about so
freely and you know people talked about
stripes and things they did that you
know most people be ashamed of or
wouldn't want to speak on and over there
you got you know you know you got credit
for doing things like that
and made me feel good basically I felt
good about the mistakes I made and which
were actually assets for the game I was
not what I brought to the Crips was I
was a master thief I didn't want to deal
with drugs I was scared to do drugs
and so obviously later on down the road
but I just I was a thief and I would
just hit heists and licks with different
groups different members different
members all over LA I was small I was
agile I could get into places no no no
no yeah we would hit we would hit stores
we'd hit armored trucks I mean a lot of
stuff we hit you've never hear about it
on the news no I think one one thing we
did is that I was a father you I heard
about any news but we hit some you know
a ten thousand twenty thousand dollar
garage full of some kind of whatever it
had in it either electronics or
something like a manager had it and
that's it's a lot of money for you know
an hour less than an hour's worth of
work
yeah I bet how I venting this it starts
getting caught up with I started getting
high started we weed our alcohol in weed
I've seen you know a little party drugs
but I eventually started doing cocaine
and with the crack and once I went to
crack I lost all respect from everybody
you know all the homies family and the
cocaine was cool because everyone's like
you know you can do cocaine sniffing but
once I started doing crack me to talk to
me that and I instantly became
quote-unquote like a crackhead like I
didn't have a you know I didn't have a
in between where I was you know just
struggling I went from nothing to first
thing I was I was it's weird cuz the
first home this homeless guy taught me
how to hustle he said there's recycle
cans and I was like alright gonna do
that so I started recycling cans a guy
who could still who could do all these
things I just figured you know how
recycle can because this is this guy
knows so I did that for a long time I
didn't I didn't even steal for for a
while but once I started stealing I
started getting a car because you're not
going the stores looking shabby sweating
like I'm sweating now
Oh skinny sucked in face anxious you
know yeah you could you could see you
could smell me from a thousand feet and
if it if you couldn't I could take a
shower and put on all brand new clothes
and be walking with a nice poodle if my
head is telling me you could see me so
I'm paranoid either way I'm gonna [ __ ]
it up in it so I started getting all
these petty thefts and you know then
that cycle just kept going and going
and out of drug and alcohol programs in
between started learning how to sell
dope figured if I sell dope it's a lot
easier because I get it from the hood
and I could take it anywhere and I don't
have to have front nothing that it's
just magic you go someone just gives you
a big pile and says give me this amount
of money you like [ __ ] but for a drug
addict like me to have that amount of
money
yeah dangerous I almost I almost got
killed a couple times but luckily the
big big big homies knew me from when I
was a kid and I brought in a lot I guess
I brought in a lot more money than I
thought doing these things so I was
valuable to him in some way so they I
mean I smoked at one time I was supposed
to bring back ten thousand dollars I
brought back 1000 and I had the audacity
to come back you know I was and I was
weird you know I talk differently yes
you know the way I speak now is how I
spoke there back then and I just had a
way of like you know making people laugh
or do something you know flipping the
script about things but you know once
once you start really hitting it like I
was hitting it he start mumbling the
words don't come out you look pitiful
yeah but uh no prison that's another
crazy thing
ever been in prison I've been a jail a
lot of times and it's something like
again in jail I mean when I go to Fort I
don't know if this makes a difference
but my mom's just tell us his back you
know being immigrants and all and not
learning it not knowing how to speak
English
she said you she say look to see that
white people dressed like them talk like
them all right okay so I mean and we
grew up around a lot of white people in
Virginia so I knew all the menu was
around you how to when I present myself
so important I was presenting myself a
totally different person and I guess I
just got what basic I just got lucky
because I mean I still had a rap sheet
of all these petty thefts and it does
when you we knew respectful even though
I was not feeling respectful towards the
system and you know it meant you know
the Criminal Courts I could fake it I
was a really good actor really good
after which you know everyone was trying
to get me to do acting and [ __ ] like
that
thank you you know you're not made for
this life you just forcing yourself and
it's true I just force myself through it
but uh I love the gangs I love
everything they brought from me dead for
me I hated some of the things we had to
do the things I had witnessed you know
you know girls women getting raped and
[ __ ] just laughing and you know
just the next day you see everybody was
up I mean if you if you knew how much
that happened you just think like like
it was a rite of passage in the
neighborhood like the women all had to
get raped hey I didn't I didn't know one
girl had been raped
maybe if she was soulfly that everyone
[ __ ] you know I'm saying or she had a
big brother or you know I'm saying like
that bit even once was a big brother
like you know somebody got him all girls
I grew up with all I've been raped
kind of that so I didn't like all that
stuff because I grew up with my mom and
sisters and stuff like that but the
violence too you know they try to
toughen me change me to be you know
witness [ __ ] and I saw some [ __ ] I can't
ever not see and I know I had to do some
[ __ ] that I you know will go to my grave
with that
that you know change me I'm gonna inside
out but you know I'm the flip side you
know he got his family you know I had a
real family but not like this family
I can't it's hard to describe what it
meant and what it is to me it I was one
of the word I didn't care about my color
all that [ __ ] I just cared about who is
in front me right there
gang life to me is family life you know
I I can't say I do I can't say I mean
it's still family gang you know they
still there for me they try but as I got
older and [ __ ] you know doing things
differently they don't even know how to
be there for me they try but you know
I'm not very showing up a defensive you
know helping me was [ __ ] that everything
need help with they might say here
here's $1,000 all right yeah take this
sack of this and I just I can't do that
I'm on you know I'm trying to do things
this way and but you know I'm saying
they do the best they can to help but it
seems like when I first got out really I
got out because I was diagnosed positive
with HIV and that kind of shook me and I
was trying to give me a suicide and the
[ __ ] and people just you know I'm saying
I just talked to the talk to the hojae's
and was like you know I'm this is it I'm
gonna commit suicide and you know I'm I
thought if you got to do what you got to
do go ahead you know our blessings you
out and I really did think I was gonna
commit suicide but
ended up not taking medications you know
things change over time but you
um having sex without condoms during my
addiction I did a lot of things for
money that men don't like to talk about
but yeah especially in the early years
where I had no control over where he
just was a monster where one once one
time I stayed up for 30 days straight 30
days straight
I know meth addicts who've never stayed
up their lungs on crack on crack yeah 30
days straight on crack I was much
younger
yeah it had a hold of me yeah I think
it's family but not the kind of not a
true real family like for my yeah no no
you know I have nothing like that you
know
you got to have a real hard stomach and
you know it started like that for me you
know growing up in Sudan and watch him
to [ __ ] I saw eyes I saw girls were my
age
having sex and getting raped in Sudan it
was I guess that just kind of I was like
five four or five I
I said see people head he chopped off
arms limbs just in the street right
there I'm just staring at body parts and
so I mean I guess I was conditioned to
this life you know from beginning you
know I wasn't much for getting queasy
but participating wasn't my thing in
that area but I knew I wanted to be a
part of it because it seemed like a
powerful thing especially in Sudan I
remember I looked up to him I looked up
to all the bigger boys running around
think they pretty much ranches you know
my mom always says his thing she goes
you know I brought you all the way here
from Africa but this he goes he goes
America's [ __ ] up you know she she
says it in a different kind of way but
that basically what she means so how
could you go all the way from Africa to
Skid Row
it's his Skid Row it's the worst thing
I've ever seen you know there's people
who don't even have shoes in Eritrea who
live better than people in Skid Row I
mean this is like he didn't mean better
like clothes wise but just happened you
know healthier safer life yeah my mom's
from you know a war-torn land she walked
through three weeks to a desert I died
in her hands she walked with me for two
days with the dead body and then
miraculously I came back to life she was
I don't know but I'm a miracle baby she
said we were on this military bus
walking through the desert the military
bus came and picked us up they said
we're gonna he's stinking we're gonna
kick him we're gonna throw his body over
my mom
like no she held on to me for a little
longer now I guess I came live they she
was my know this dog his sister she had
when she was 12 so I think she was
running like 16 17 at the time I don't
know something really young she was
really young yeah when she did that
trick so she's seen a lot of [ __ ] you
know women fight wars over there but
when she came to skid row and seen how
I've been living
she couldn't handle it she's like this
is worse than any place in Africa I've
ever seen yeah she's still in Virginia
yeah she's coming over here a couple of
times looking for me
this is especially in the earlier days
when I was I was just like straight
street got her today I liked it I mean I
use occasionally but not it does you
know I have a have a place to live today
you know it's just different
I have been up a couple days because you
know the first of the month a lot of
people have money so you just go around
and get high for free but you know it's
not it's not an everyday thing I mean I
had a good really good job recently for
a couple years I was working in
treatment but you know I lost that due
to relapse yeah but you know I I could
keep a phone listen why no I mean I'm
doing enough to survive
being here other than mission and yeah
well yeah there's a guy who worked there
who's one of my roommates there and I
relapse right and then the next day is
longer I take one hit and I lose like 20
pounds I think I saw him a couple weeks
later and he's a big guy way bigger than
me and he held me at knifepoint she took
me to this house you know we were
supposed to be sent for money I was like
nine do not legit you know I and he you
know he had a knife and a gun and he
raped me and I had never had sex and he
he was open about his age status and
honestly the that's really where I think
we're I know I got it I like to say just
sex without condoms because it makes me
sound like you know I'm saying it's an
irresponsible gigolo or something but
you know that's probably the worst thing
that ever happened to me I couldn't get
a took a while for me just stop thinking
about killing him but I couldn't stop
because I kept using and when you using
like the last thing you want to do is go
take care of any kind of business even
if you mean revenge business they using
kind of primary to everything
his last relapse hasn't been as bad
because I there would develop you know
you know get a foundation get a place
live all these good things and now I'm
just trying to hold on to it and you
know not try to go to jail or do
anything stupid cuz you know I'm old
enough smart enough you know I know
people you know it's just it's easy to
just get a drill if I wanted it's not
that soon what makes it easier is the
drug so I mean they're trying to kill
you basically last night
there's one deal that he knows I always
have money it was mad because I wouldn't
buy from him and he laced a crack rock
with some embalming fluid and I thought
I thought no the end for me but for some
reason I just I was really strong I
didn't some reason I started eating and
drinking water and booming I don't know
to me it lasted thirty minutes it could
have been four or five hours but I'm
glad I made it through you know take a
risk out here every day for just [ __ ]
yeah yeah been clean many times you know
trees you go there
we're to say but it's instant family
it's instant community it's instant you
know you're a part of something right
away you know you don't have to be work
your way fat you know I've always liked
things fast I come out here and pull my
the community I could be the leader of
this I could do this I could be the best
that this quick if people come and go
you know I'm saying as far as in real
life where you know it takes a long time
to develop the voices of the people you
know here we see each other all day
every day you get a relationship quick
capable room where the next one in the
room everything's fast moving I like you
know I feel alive like I've been on the
phone for like three months I noticed
that yesterday I'm on the train and I'm
looking at everybody like this I'm like
wow remember I used to be like that and
I used to feel like if I wasn't like
that how am I gonna make it on this
train for the next eight four stop
there's no way I can make it without my
phone my phone dies it's over but now I
ride from one line to the end and it
feels like nothing you know it is really
it has some qualities to it being
homeless and you know you talk to people
you you're a you know you're engaged
with the world around you you have no
other choice or you go crazy and start
talking to yourself we did a lot of
[ __ ] do I don't want to be that
guy if I'm desperate to talk somebody I
will I'll go find an old person I'll go
find a crazy person yeah
yeah my plan is to get 100% sober you
know I know it doesn't work trying to do
little drugs hearing it and I don't know
there's no specific thing I want to do I
just want to be productive and be a part
of you know helping society you know pay
taxes whatever but the hobbies I'd like
to you know participate in is just
giving back and being present for young
kids who were in gangs no message no
nothing just there someone who's made it
through who's on the other side just you
know Big Brother man having a big
brother I always dreamed I was like God
please let me have because I don't know
how to do this I didn't know how to have
sex I had to listen you know 10 10 year
old so tell me
[Music]
advise of guys you have to say
but just not being that person needs to
get to the connectivity
yeah some of the people my best girl
models are people who I can't even
remember our conversations I remember
just what they did
never how they did how they did school
what he did after school and that my mom
was funny because she didn't drink or
anything but she was not lazy and they
know me as mr. Hyde
it's impossible for me to not knock the
urge to be lazy like my mom gonna sit on
the curb and play dice and I can't do
that I just can't I gotta be moving or
doing something even if it means going
to help somebody do something for free I
don't want to die you know so death to
me is stagnation just sitting there
watching cop cars go by squirming and
[ __ ]
I want to live and gangs gave me that
best the best I'm from what I've
experienced so far one of the best
opportunities like that you know - all
the other [ __ ] we did I really felt
alive doing everything every day I woke
up you know I watched those movies you
know you know denier or whatever some
people may be they get excited but I
lived it so I mean not like you know I
mean I wasn't like in you know different
countries they said but you know I did a
lot of exciting [ __ ] so it doesn't
impress me to see other people lived
that way you know I just want to live
and now being sober or trying to get
sober I want to be the same thing I
don't want to be on my phone I want to
be participating in doing whatever I do
to be yeah yeah I had one I met her when
I went back home to err sure to visit
and she was a she's a beautiful person
we had a three month thing got married
we didn't tell our parents we heard that
in fact country our culture is biggest
nono and no one knew about me and her
they just knew that's Simon the dude who
gave my real name the dude who never
even [ __ ] with girls I had a
girlfriend like that they brought one
home all of a sudden wants to get
married is obsessed over this woman and
she was she was officer she she could
speak like five languages
she like 588 like 110 pounds dude for
body perfect and the thing that I
remember thing that got me we were at
the university libraries just talking
and the bird walk flew into a wall and
she said hold on and she picked up the
bird and she said go give me a cup of
sugar and water and mix it up are you
doing she took it she put the sugar
water in her mouth and fed the bird out
of her mouth then put the bird on her
shoulder and she goes come on loose to
keep talking watching five minutes
she'll have energy to fly away and she
did and this was a beautiful model type
kind of girl wearing these flip-flops
with like I like no woman in America no
girl I mean you know that I ever ran
across would ever touch an animal and
then it just didn't to me she just blew
my mind and she was way smarter than me
to philosophy math she just keep doing
math and type of read like that I did it
yeah
anyway but on top of that we just
connected we disconnected me after I
left back to California I couldn't do
the paperwork that I needed to do to
send her over here I couldn't pull off
going into an office and so I sit in the
corner somewhere and feel the press and
be like ah I can't do it and I miss her
and I love her but I can't do it just
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] and one
day her uncle cami he actually came to
where I was at I was like the only way
this is going to happen he someone needs
to come exactly where I'm at at that
time to get me to do this paperwork it
happened and then she stayed with me
like officially you know we were like
still she joined the military and she
she she's a marksman
she can shoot everyone in her chair goes
to army so she can she's really good
shooter so she got up with the general
some dudes and she started studying
about drugs and remember her on the
phone saying Simon you know you love
this crack [ __ ] and she loved crack I
won't I'm gonna try crack with her
broken I got I was like are you serious
she's like yeah I want to try it because
if this thing comes you know is more
important than me I I want to enjoy
something that's more important than
someone I love it must be really good
and you know quirky where
joking you know she's that you know she
would have but uh then she stayed with
me and she finished her two years of
military and I still couldn't pull it
off I still can our divorce paperwork
that she needed to move on and she was
going to graduate school she had to fly
in from at the time Susan she knew she's
in school in Arizona somewhere she flew
in for like Arizona with a notary and
the hotel of my choice closes the Skid
Row that I liked I like this the
standard I said for me to sign the
divorce paperwork because I I couldn't
pull it off any other way it we have
been trying to do it with me for like
six or seven months she's like I'm all
you gotta do sign it because and when
you do I could do this this is it
because she was in full citizen yeah so
that's that paperwork was real important
but she had to fly in that day come with
her notaries and that's how stuck I was
that's how important drugs were
I ten no ever see I'm 40 years old now
30 about 15 or 12 something like that
I don't even know the dates and times I
I know everything to my friends back
home who say oh yeah remember you called
me from that program in Arizona yeah you
did this and then the district or they
won the championship I don't know it's a
big blow a lot of is it's a big blur and
that's why I like the life out here
because it's so hard to give up just
like because it's a it's a blur just
keep going action it's it's even if
you're not even a part of it you got so
many spectators out here you know want
to be gang members people who just love
to watch the shoot they pretend like his
bone you know [ __ ] are ignorant but
they literally are spectators they come
out here got chairs and they sit for
hours ten twelve hours and then they
pretend them to have some fake-ass
household like selling candy no they're
so excited they wanna they want to do
what we do but they just don't have it
thank you
thank you